m eps meeting in brussels for a micro
cleaner II heard a statement from the
European Commission on counterterrorism
measures following the deadly attacks in
Paris views are divided between those
wanting new measures including sharing
more information on air passengers and
those who want better police
collaboration the most important thing
is actually sharing intelligence and
that is we're very well known for a long
time and that is exactly what member
states have not been doing even worse
they have not been funding adequately
our intelligence and security service
members voted to debate a resolution on
counterterrorism in February next
December in Paris potentially 196
countries may sign a new agreement on
climate change but as M eps discussed
there will be a lot of negotiating
before then to ensure the agreement is a
binding and meaningful one each novelist
via via of adjacent shown for Lima
mining Elena zph that's why I good
sighing let's wingler with us via in
Paris I'm in these showers so I'm a good
negate miscomm Verdun if Paris delivers
on keeping the rise in global
temperatures to below two degrees
Celsius it could be the deal that saves
the planet